- Probably the thing that's
most on my mind right now.
Like, fuck man, I have
to do this for me and
humanity (laughs),
that's how big of an ego I have,
to stay alive for a long time
so I can see this through.
I know I'm on to something
so fundamentally different
and I know that
I can inspire people to do it
'cause it's gonna
have the empire part too.
See that's what
people don't get.
The reason I'm gonna win
is because I've got both.
The honey part means
that you want to
go change the world.
The empire part means
you'll do it at all costs.
I'm neither.
It's cool.
It's really interesting.
Because when I buy the Jets,
there's going to be
a lot of nice people
that are 13
that are gonna think they can
build a nice big business thing,
do it the right way.
I'm gonna redefine what
an entrepreneur and
businessperson is thought of.
I think I can do it.